in this video we're going to talk about
how to get your thyroid to work better
there's a lot of people that have
thyroid problems and a lot of people are
taking medication for it but what about
the actual underlying cause and what
could we do to correct the function of
that thyroid and hopefully down the road
you'll need less medication and maybe
you won't need any medication at all so
here's the thing you need to know you
have the pituitary which is in the brain
it releases a hormone called thyroid
stimulating hormone the purpose of this
hormone is to tell the thyroid to
release t4 and t3 okay t4 is the
inactive thyroid hormone t3 is the
active thyroid hormone so t4 actually
converts to t3 we have like 23 times
more t4 than we do t3 so this is kind of
like the the pre hormone it's like the
reserve then this actually does the work
in all of the cells and it controls the
speed of your metabolism the digestion
your mood so if you're cold if you're
losing your hair if you're sluggish
mentally and physically and you have
muscle weakness those are all real
common symptoms of a slow thyroid now
check this out this isn't a feedback
loop so as soon as the thyroid
stimulating hormone tells the thyroid to
release t4 there's a negative feedback
that comes up there and tells the
pituitary I have enough so if you have
low thyroid stimulating hormone that
means you have enough I mean you might
have too much but you have enough you
don't need more on the other hand if
it's high if this hormone is high that
means your body needs more of these
hormones so it's then going to increase
to produce more of these hormones now
there's really two main problems with a
hypo thyroid condition either you're not
making enough thyroid hormone usually t4
or you're not converting t4 to t3 so
let's first talk about the converge
in order to convert t4 to t3 you need Co
factors you need Helper vitamins &
Minerals all these nutrients help
contribute to this conversion selenium
is on the top of list this is the most
important okay and you have iodine then
you have vitamin D vitamin a zinc b2 b6
b12 and iron now if you're doing a
healthy ketogenic diet and you're doing
intermittent fasting like I recommend in
my book you're eating foods that would
give you these right here also when
you're doing healthy keto in a minute
fasting the need for t3 goes way down so
it's going to overall help the thyroid
but these are the key nutrients that
help this conversion now as far as the
production of more thyroid hormones
what's usually happening is something is
suppressing the function of the thyroid
and it's usually high cortisol that
comes from stress it could also be from
medications like prednisone cortisone
shots things like that also estrogen is
a big factor this is why you see women
right after pregnancy for example end up
with a hypothyroid case because the
spike in estrogen now if you're taking
birth control pills or you're on HRT
that can inhibit the production also
high levels of insulin if you're doing a
high carb diet if you have PCOS for
example plasticity co-variants syndrome
that can inhibit t4 now I should have
put this one over here because this has
to do with more conversions 80% of the
conversion from t4 to t3 happens in the
liver 20% happens in the kidney and if
there's a problem with the liver if
there's a problem with the gallbladder
if you had your gallbladder removed what
will happen is you're not going to get
the conversion so a real simple solution
is to take purify bile salts that will
instantly improve the conversion now on
the flip side if you have a hyper
thyroid condition hyper too much thyroid
you don't want to take bile salts
because that's gonna give you more and
it's going to worsen the situation only
if you have a hypo thyroid condition and
for those of you that are new if you're
on the keto plan the healthy keto plan
and in the fasting the need for t3 will
go down and this alone will greatly
improve a thyroid function and you may
even find that you need to make some
adjustments to your medication because
it's going to start improving other
things that can interfere with thyroid
function and acids high blood pressure
medications statins diuretics
antibiotics excessive iron so an iron
deficiency will create a problem in the
conversion but too much iron can also
create a problem with the conversion
from t4 to t3 then you have phytic acid
which is in grains it's in the brand of
grains that will deplete your zinc and
that will throw off your conversions
coffee and tea will deplete you of
certain nutrients like the B vitamins
and so I just want to bring that to your
attention if you have a lot of iced tea
for example or a lot of coffee
you better be taking nutrients at the
same time because it could affect the
thyroid and of course the reason why
keto works is because it's a little carb
so that means too much sugar or refined
carbs are definitely going to mess up
your thyroid soy will act as an estrogen
and inhibit the thyroid as well and also
because dairy has so many different
types of hormones that can influence the
thyroid now if you have an autoimmune
condition Hashimoto's then I'm going to
put a link down below because I did a
video on this specifically but you need
vitamin D okay like at least 20,000 IU's
per day you need to be doing a bit of
fasting and you need to be taking
selenium to improve the function of the
thyroid and this is mainly going to be
for Hashimoto's but Hashimoto's is the
majority of hypothyroid cases alright
thanks for watching so if you want more
knowledge on how to create a healthy
body subscribe now and get daily
notifications